[Musique]
je suis rejoints par l'un des plus
fameux intellectuelle de la planète le
père de la linguistique moderne le
dissident américain noam chomsky
merci infiniment de revenir dans notre
émission qu'est ce que le global green
new deal c'est le titre de votre nouveau
livre climate crisis and the global
green new deal et qu'est ce que pour
vous et pour toi c'est le programme
politique le plus important de toute
l'histoire de l'humanité nous faisons
aujourd'hui face à un certain nombre de
crises de grave
l'une d'elles est la menace de
catastrophe environnementale ou j'te il
nous faut arriver à un taux d'émission
nul d'ici quelques décennies est l'un
des buts goodwin inutile et de fournir
les moyens de le faire mais de l'autre
problème qui émerge de manière très
sérieuse à l'heure actuelle c'est
l'effondrement de l'économie
en conséquence de la trentaine c'est une
crise bien différente de la crise
financière et un choc au genou
cette fois on ne s'en sortira pas via la
consommation en renflouant les marchés
financiers cela n'aidera en rien et nous
il nous faut fonder une nouvelle
économie qui offre de bons emplois dans
le travail constructif développer les
infrastructures sociales des structures
environnementale physiques dont nous
avons besoin les produits dont nous
avons besoin pour mener une vie décente
c'est la seconde moitié du grignotage
est essentielle non seulement pour notre
survie
mais aussi pour une survie c'est vous
avez mentionné le coronavirus
2 comment le coronavirus affecte-t-il
votre analyse étant donné que le
coronavirus a aussi un impact sur les
profits des entreprises de manière
intéressante cela n'a pas encore
d'impact sur la majorité des profits des
entreprises et les riches enjoy beaucoup
d'entre elles font de l'argent très
rapidement dans la haute technologie par
exemple de vous rejoindre
il y a eu une journée durant laquelle
jeff bezos a amassé 13 milliards de
dollars les hedge funds les fonds de
placement privé se porte bien parce que
le trésor injecte de l'argent dans
l'économie d'une manière qui leur
profite largement si l'on regarde
l'économie
prenons les états unis mais c'est
partout sur la planète les marchés
financiers bat des records et la
pauvreté bat des records chant elle
aurait agi sont totalement à l'opposé et
c'est un symptôme de la grave maladie
qui touche l'économie et qui ne peut
être surmontée que par le développement
de politiques définies dans les détails
des propositions du green new deal
comment considérez-vous le reformatage
permanent par les entreprises de la
crise climatique
c'est aux gens ordinaires de recycler
d'acheter les produits bio s'il s'agit
plus d'eux que d'un changement
systémique
naturellement ceux qui tirent bénéfice
des institutions existantes ne veulent
pas qu'elle change serait pas surprenant
si vous avez une dictature totalitaire
et qu'il ya des problèmes
le dictateur ne va pas dire en ré c'est
moi c'est comparable à ce que vous
décrivez le coeur du problème c'est la
production de masse avait faim de
profits privés et non par nécessité
nature et le recours aux combustibles
fossiles alors on devrait s'en
débarrasser
évoluer vers une énergie renouvelable
total vers une absence d'émissions d'ici
quelques décennies nous avons vu avec
des scientifiques comment la
déforestation a engendré la crise du
cornât virus le livre vous dites que
même des stratégies comme le raid
le r e d'aidés sont financés par des
entreprises pour mettre un terme à la
déforestation mais dans votre livre vous
dites que ça l'encouragent que ça aide
les très grandes fermes au détriment des
autres comment sait-il que encore et
toujours ses stratégies soutenu par les
gouvernements et la banque mondiale dans
ce cas précis elle semble avoir l'effet
inverse de celui attendu
il est possible qu'ils aient de bonnes
intentions mais ils sont forcés par la
nature du pouvoir institutionnel de
faire des programmes qui ne nuiront pas
aux puissantes institutions de la
société principalement le secteur privé
mais au contraire se conformeront à
leurs besoins il en résulte des
politiques qui peu importe leurs
intentions ont souvent des effets
négatifs
ouidah nous devons prendre en main ces
problèmes directement et sans donner la
priorité aux besoins de ces institutions
destructrice et du jeu nous n'avons pas
le temps de les vaincre et les éliminer
il faut que nous nous adaptions à leur
existence l'échelle temporelle des
institutions est hors de portée de
celles que nous avons pour faire face à
la crise environnementale
oui il nous faut donc travailler dans
les infrastructures institutionnelles de
base qui existe mais il faut en leur
sein
trouver des politiques très clair elles
sont mises en avant dans la contribution
de mon collègue bob pauline choiseul
j'm'en des politiques qui avec un faible
pourcentage de l'est
me suffiront pour faire face à ces deux
problèmes
votre livre va plus au incliné selon
laquelle on faire est pavé de bonnes
intentions
car peut-être que cela en choquera
certains vous utilisez le terme
malveillants prononce qui a lieu devant
nous ces derniers jours avec le soutien
actif du secteur privé l'administration
trump a supprimé des régulations show
which qui protégeait la population et
l'environnement
un éleveur de la diffusion de méthane
d'arsenic et d'autres déchets toxiques
au bénéfice du système privé à seulement
des entreprises d'extraction d'énergies
fossiles mais aussi aux des banques qui
les financent les en profite mais ça
nuit à l'environnement et ça nuit au
peuple américain
il s'en fiche si ce n'est pas
malveillant qu'est ce que c'est il ya
peut-être quelqu'un dans la salle qui
dit ce serait bien de penser à
l'environnement ce serait bien des
légendes et quand on revient au choix
spécifique de maximiser le profit et les
parts de marché toutes ces bonnes
intentions du deviennent secondaires
dans le livre il est dit que le plein
emploi est une des clés escrime pauline
site karl marx en disant que le
capitalisme a besoin du chômage pour
restreindre la capacité de négociation
des travailleurs il implique le plein
emploi
souvenez vous que nous ne vivons pas
dans le type de société capitaliste que
marx analysait ce que marx décrivait
assez bien une forme abstraite de
capitalisme qui met en évidence sa
nature même d'un show late show
donc toute société ng d'une manière ou
d'une autre une sorte de capitalisme
d'état ou sous pression populaire
l'action publique est là pour atténuer
les formes destructrice du capitalisme
pur donc oui le capitalisme pur comme le
dit marc a besoin d'une armée de réserve
de travailleurs mais le capitalisme
d'état peut surmonter ce problème et
garantir les emplois et même des emplois
décents à tout le monde cela ne résout
en rien tous les problèmes du
capitalisme en fait nous approchions
formellement du plein emploi avec la
réponse molle apportée par obama à la
crise financière est poursuivi par
donald trump
ce n'était pas le genre de plein emploi
que quelqu'un de normal voudrait une
bonne partie consistait en emploi
extrêmement précaire et très mal payés
est ce que quelqu'un comme vous et
surpris de voir à quel point le
capitalisme tend à renforcer les
systèmes de pouvoir au sein des élites
alors même que ça peut mettre en danger
leurs propres enfants cherchent un lieu
chez eux
supposez que vous soyez le directeur de
jean ping
la plus grosse banque août exxon mobil
vous avez en gros deux choix et je te
mets l'un est de se plier aux exigences
des structures institutionnelles
existantes et de travailler pour le
profit maximal même importe de les
conséquences humaines c'est le premier
choix d'ailleurs deux choses je t'écoute
l'autre est de les mettre de côté et
travailler à édifier un monde descend du
supposé que vous faites ce choix dans ce
cas vous êtes immédiatement évacuée par
le conseil d'administration ait
quelqu'un d'autre qui fera le premier
choix et mieux à votre place ce sont des
problèmes institut
lionel à des problèmes individuels ce
qui ne veut pas dire qu'on ne peut rien
y faire au sein des institutions
existantes
on peut changer les choses et j'ai
repris mon l'exemple de jp morgan
la plus grosse banque un mémo interne à
la banque a récemment fui dit c'était
très intéressant
il mettait en garde les directeurs de la
banque du fait que selon leurs propres
termes la survie de l'humanité est
menacée si nous continuons à financer
les énergies fossiles philo il ajoutait
que la banque risquait de voir sa
réputation entachée
c'est à dire que je cite la population
commence à être furieuse et se vengera
sur vous s'en prendra à vous les
directeurs de la banque
à moins que vous ne preniez des mesures
pour sauver l'humanité de la destruction
sinon le contrôle des banques sera pris
par le public et elles seront
nationalisées
fin de citation ce qui est faisable
remplacé par des banques publiques tout
cela est faisable et les leaders de
l'économie savent que leur contrôle est
assez fragile auteurs de ce crime
jo c'est bien tout semble être
nationalisées ici en angleterre
du moins plus qui après la crise de 2008
sa cause de la pandémie et des gens se
font arrêter dans les rues de londres
dans le cadre des manifestations d
extinction rebéllion mais la banque jp
morgan dit en public et non dans un mémo
qui aurait fuité et qu'il y a plus de
prêts pour le forage d'énergies fossiles
dans l'arctique ce qu'ils arrêtent les
prêts pour l'extraction de charbon et le
prévoit 200 milliards pour ce qu'ils
appellent l'autonomisation de
développement économique avec goldman
sachs imaginez que le patron
d'exxonmobil et de shell disent oui il
ya bien un changement climatique
oui les énergies renouvelables sont une
part indispensable du futur mix
énergétique
mais mettre un coup d'arrêt soudain aux
combustibles fossiles on n'est pas une
option envisageable
la pause bompas et bien il faut
expliquer au public que c'est faux je
vais neurones poursuivre leurs propres
intérêts
il faut faire pression sur eux pour
qu'ils les abandonnent ce discours
hainaut et qu'il fasse ce qui est juste
pour en finir avec le charbon me way et
avec sous les combustibles fossiles
aussi vite que possible
il y à une lutte des classes et la
classe dirigeante ne peut pas dire je
vais faire ce que je veux et je me fiche
de votre sort ils ne peuvent pas ils
n'ont pas ce pouvoir sera jo leur
pouvoir est fragile ils le savent et
c'est pourquoi ils doivent conditionner
une population résolu stimuler et active
comme cela a souvent été fait par le
passé
le green new deal contient l'expression
new deal car le new deal dans les années
30 était quelque chose de tout à fait
similaire c'était insuffisant mais
c'était le même genre de choses m
un de faire une action gouvernementale
pour surmonter une crise une grave crise
engendrée par les problèmes fondamentaux
d'une société capitaliste des eaux puis
est venue la guerre induisant des
dépenses publiques bien plus importante
que tout ce qui est nécessaire
aujourd'hui un des deux mettant fin à la
dépression créant une grande demande
menant à plusieurs décennies de
croissance plutôt rapide des plutôt
équitable
chomsky je vous arrête là a tout de
suite après la pause
[Musique]
bonjour je suis toujours avec le
dissident américain est important
hauteur de la fabrication du
consentement noam chomsky
vous avez mentionné chine le new deal on
a vu que les primaires démocrates
n'avaient pas investi bernie sanders qui
est en faveur de politiques du type du
new deal ici en angleterre jérémy corby
n'a perdu les élections
à quoi vous attendez vous pour novembre
vous dites dans votre livre que les
démocrates sont dans la poche des
lobbyistes de wall street
vous comparez les républicains ont
parfois périphériques et de droite en
europe
c'est exact les républicains sont à
l'heure actuelle totalement en dehors du
spectre ils sont si on opère une
comparaison internationale
proche des partis à tendance néo
fasciste en europe et je joue est grand
et même pour les questions
environnementales ce sont les pires de
la planète
[Musique]
l'administration trump veut maximiser
l'usagé des combustibles fossiles et
mettre à bas le système de régulation
qui atténue d'une certaine manière leurs
effets destructeurs sur le climat et sur
la population
ils font ça tout à fait ouvertement il
n'en fait pas mystère
jetez un oeil à la convention
républicaine pas un mot à ce sujet ils
ne cherchent qu à exciter les émotions
des gens leur peur la peur concernant le
suprématisme blanc la peur on leur
enlève leurs armes toutes considérations
émotionnelles que vous puissiez imaginer
cela est très proche des régimes
autocratiques de type néo fasciste
abonnés à feu et au sein des démocrates
il y à un conflit un conflit tout à fait
frappant déchets de cross vous pouvez le
voir si vous observez ce qui se passe
prenons le climat regardé sur internet
et chercher le programme démocrate pour
le climat d'il ya quelques semaines
c'était un programme assez progressistes
le programme de weiden le
on lui a donné il ne l'a pas choisi
c'était un programme assez progressistes
mieux que tous les autres programmes
ayant existé jusqu'à maintenant fait la
même recherche aujourd'hui sur internet
vous ne trouverez rien et winamax
le comité national démocrate à clinton
ise c'est à dire qu'ils ont là un vrai
jeu de pouvoir supprimer le programme
progressiste de byden sur le climat
c'est une lutte au sein du parti
démocrate
c'est très similaire à ce à quoi on
vient d'assister en angleterre où la
tendance blairiste la tendance de droite
du parti travailliste a réussi à miner
la campagne de corps been de manière
très vicieuse il y à une étude détaillée
de 800 pages sur comment ils ont fait ça
une étude qui a été en grande partie
passé sous silence dans la presse
britannique mais qui est très importante
et montre ce à quoi ils ont eu recours
pour miner les efforts de corps d'une
part développer un parti travailliste
qui répondrait aux attentes de ses
électeurs
un parti travailliste participatif qui
bénéficiait d'une forte approbation les
éléments de droite du parti travailliste
ne supportait pas sa préférée perdre
l'élection plutôt que de perdre le
contrôle du parti a une chance et notre
langue nous voyons quelque chose de
similaire avec le conflit au sein du
parti démocrate aujourd'hui est ce que
cela implique
c'est que la base progressiste doit
travailler plus dur avec plus d'énergie
plus
d'engagement au cas où byden gagnerait
l'élection pour s'assurer du retour au
programme progressiste qui a été
initialement annoncé un homme et pour ne
pas être forcées de l'abandonner face
aux éléments conservateurs qu'une dognin
du parti parce qu'on appelait en gros
autrefois les républicains modérés
mais tout cela n'est rien par rapport à
la nécessité impérieuse de se
débarrasser de la malveillance qui se
trouve à la maison blanche
wesh peu importe les critiques que l'on
peut faire aux démocrates est
incomparablement plus grave et qui si on
lui laisse les mains libres nous
détruira nous invitons sur caire
strummer a réfuté ce que vous avez dit
au sujet du parti travailliste même s'il
veut une enquête
quant à notre droit de diffuser
concernant joe biden apparemment la
politique n'a pas changé
deux mille milliards de dollars pour
l'énergie propre quatre millions
d'immeubles en plus une tentative de se
tourner vers les transports publics
comme vous le savez récemment joe biden
a dit pas d'interdiction de la
fracturation hydraulique
le green new deal a tellement d'aspects
différents des as bref le 10 mai alors
que des corps de réfugiés sont retrouvés
dans la manche
chara vous dites dans ce livre et spock
you say les pays riches sont dans le
pétrin parce qu'une fraction des
réfugiés pourraient profane et leur
précieuse pureté ethnique et vous citer
aussi les chiffres de l'onu à 65
millions de réfugiés fuyant les
violences les persécutions et le
réchauffement climatique
pourquoi pensez vous que nos médias les
présente comme des migrants et disent
que le véritable ennemi et le trafic
d'êtres humains et non la politique
étrangère pour la raison que vous venez
de mentionner votre commentaire ironique
et précis à propos de la profanation de
notre pureté raciale
oui chine nous avons déjà vu ça dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est scandaleux c'est choquant cela
doit être surmonté
la réaction de l'europe à la crise des
réfugiés est ignoble
l'europe va dans les pays les plus
pauvres d'afrique comme le niger ont
exigé et pour essayer d'empêcher les
gens de fuir les décombres de
l'impérialisme européen afin de
s'assurer qu'ils n'arrivent pas sur les
côtes européennes
choqués ils corrompent la turquie pour
les maintenir loin de nous il ya une
raison pour laquelle ces gens fuient ce
n'est pas parce qu'ils aiment l'europe
c'est à cause des conditions
intolérables dans lesquelles ils vivent
largement créé par la terreur et la
violence européenne pendant des siècles
c'est désormais la responsabilité de
l'europe de se comporter humainement
envers eux un matt hall et ne pas user
de prétextes raciste pour les punir pour
les crimes de l'europe
en somme c'est la même chose ici
quand le président trump exige du
mexique
s'ils empêchent les réfugiés d'amérique
centrale de rejoindre le territoire des
états unis pour demander l'asile auquel
ils ont de toute évidence 3 pourquoi
futile l'amérique centrale
parce qu'ils n'aiment pas leur maison
mais parce que la violence terroriste
des etats unis a détruit leur pays il ya
pas mal de livres que vous avez écrit
concernant ce que vous considérez comme
de la violence et du terrorisme
mais je dois vous demandez vous seriez
néanmoins d'accord avec donald trump
quand il dit que notre première
imminente menace est une apocalypse
nucléaire due aux arsenaux nucléaires
être d'accord avec toi
aggrave la menace des armes nucléaires
c'est pourquoi l'horloge de l'apocalypse
la fameuse horloge de la fin du monde
nous a été avancé d'une minute et s'est
rapproché de minuit chaque année durant
laquelle trône pas été président en
janvier les minutes sont passées aux
seconds 100 secondes avant minuit
shenzhen depuis janvier trump a
poursuivi ses attaques sur le contrôle
des armements et qui a d'une certaine
manière à atténuer la menace de
destruction nucléaire il n'y a déjà plus
de traiter inf il y a quelques mois il a
détruit le traité ciel ouvert qui datent
d'ailleurs il est il retarde pour des
raisons frivole la mise en oeuvre du
renouvellement du traité new star et il
est peut être désormais trop tard pour
le renouveler et c'est le dernier des
traités majeur il est allé encore plus
loin en menaçant de commencer à faire
des essais nucléaires ce qui n'a pas été
fait depuis 28 ans et au delà de ça il
va vers la création de nouvelles armes
encore plus menaçante contre lesquels il
n'y a aucun moyen de se défendre
de ce point de vue les démocrates n'ont
pas de quoi être fier je dois dire mais
ce n'est rien comparé à trump
l'ambassadeur des états unis dit au
sujet de donald trump et qu'il est pour
la paix j'avoue poser une question
concernant julian assange de wikileaks
le procès de sa vie a commencé à la cour
de londres
un rapporteur
l'onu qui a été dans cette émission a
dit qu'il avait été torturé par les
autorités britanniques
que pensez vous que cela signifiera si
le fondateur de wikileaks est extradé
vers les états unis pour des accusations
d'espionnage
ce serait criminel de la part du
gouvernement britannique de se plier aux
demandes d'extradition des états unis
ils sont les auteurs de nombreux crimes
inchangée alors que le crime café
assange est de ne pas avoir payé sa
caution d'accord il avait de bonnes
raisons
car sinon il aurait été extradé et ne
pas payer sa caution mérite ma tape sur
les doigts à la torture dans une prison
de haute sécurité
il n'est même pas autorisé à recevoir
les livres à ma mère je veux dire c'est
pire que pour les meurtriers de masse
pour les criminels les plus vicieux ok
s'il est extradé il aura un procès se
fondant sur les lois américaines sur
l'espionnage which ce qui peut même
faire peser sur lui la menace de la
peine de mort
il est jugé pour avoir commis le crime
d'informer la population de choses
qu'elle a le droit de savoir
ce n est que de puissants états ne
veulent pas qu'elle sache voilà son
climat mme delord la manière d'agir du
gouvernement britannique est déplorable
et la pression populaire doit se
renforcer pour qu'on s'assure que ces
accusations soient rapidement levées et
que plus aucune menace ne pèse sur lui
[Musique]